- [Narrator] Fancy going shopping?
- Stop!
No, no, no, no whistling
in the Burlington Arcade.
- [Narrator] Uh, who are you?
- We are the Burlington's Beadles,
probably the oldest and smallest
police force in the world.
You could say, that we
police your manners.
- [Narrator] Right, okay.
Well, Mark Lord, Head Beadle
of the Burlington Arcade,
tell us your story.
- The Beadles' story started-
- [Narrator] Before we get into that,
what actually is a Beadle?
- To be honest with you, I don't
think anybody really knows.
We predate any police
force in the country.
- [Narrator] Right, back to
the story, go ahead, Mark.
- The Beadles' story
started at this arcade.
- [Narrator] Arcade?
Are there games here?
- No.
(hearty chuckle)
- [Narrator] So, it's just
like a shopping center right?
- Yes.
- [Narrator] Okay, third
time lucky, go ahead Mark.
- The Beadles' story started
on the 20th of March 1819.
London was very different,
people didn't really
trust the waters, so they
drank either gin or beer
and obviously that leads to
a certain type of behavior.
So the Beadles' role, really was to keep
all that from the arcade and in fact,
that tradition has carried on
all the way through to today.
Our uniforms are made up of
several different layers.
We first of all, put on our waistcoats,
then our frock coats and
our top hats in the summer
or the autumn, in the winter, you'll still
put on your waistcoats, you will
then put on your cape and your top hat.
The original rules here were, no whistling
because the pickpockets will
whistle signals to one another.
No drunkenness, playing
musical instrument,
you're not supposed to
hurry, it's ungentleman-like
or unlady-like, carry your own parcels,
you mustn't bring a bicycle.
Unaccompanied ladies
by the way, weren't also allowed in.
Now, lots of those rules
we couldn't enforce today.
We've still tried to
enforce the no hurrying,
we still try to enforce the no whistling,
it's all about behavior, as
long as you're respecting
those around you and
respecting the arcade,
you'll be left alone.
When I put this uniform on, I represent
nearly 200 years worth of history.
Makes me immensely
proud, yeah, I wanna stay
until I retire, if I'm honest with you.
That's actually true by the way,
it isn't just the spill.